this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond dnd is for everyone
dnd beyond makes it easy to play
register for free at dnd beyond.com to
start your adventure
[Music]
the franchise that's been rebooted more
times than lieutenant dangle has
returned new boot goofing
oh and after making a killing in
theaters one thing is for sure
people would rather get covered than
sign up for peacock
halloween kills
you thrilled as the strodes faced off
against michael myers now get ready to
see what literally everyone else in town
was up to that night from dr loomis's
nurse to the kid laura used to babysit
to the kid lori's friend used to babysit
to the kid they used to bully the kid
that laura used to babysit all of
haddenfield will band together to
reminisce about that five minutes of
scream time they got 40 years ago 40
years ago a madman escaped from a mental
hospital he killed my daughter 40 years
ago he's infected my family with grief
and fear for 40 years michael myers has
haunted this town for 40 years 40 years
ago when i was a kid you protected me
michael myers has returned extra crispy
he'll pick up right where he left off
mindlessly killing people
then very mindfully arranging their
bodies in an artful tableau
hmm it's missing a certain genesecua
perhaps one more knife
right
there and the only thing standing in his
path is franchise star wars lori strode
no she might as well be in a coma okay
standing in the way of mike is alison
strode the next in line to take over the
franchise no she immediately proves she
isn't worthy
okay standing in the way of mike is
karen strode who finally realized her
mom was right and became the badass she
was raised to become no she's still
trying to calm things down
wow okay standing in the way of mike are
two gay pirates and an elderly couple
with a drone cool because this was
clearly the middle part of a trilogy and
this killer is craving some filler for
halloween do you know what happens to
people who come into the myers home
without an invitation we're not even
scared he stabbed his sister
you were impressed confused to learn
danny mcbride helped write these reboots
but it takes someone like kenny powers
to write characters this stupid
as all of haddonfield fights back on
halloween night in the dumbest ways
possible whether they're splitting into
smaller and smaller groups
okay so the key is we stick together now
i'm going in alone what falling for the
same tricks they did 40 years ago
mistaking a danny devito look alike for
michael myers even though they all grew
up with him and his face is on the
it's not news and showing up to a
climactic beatdown in their pjs look
that guy brought a hockey stick who
plays cricket in haddonfield illinois
they're going with a clothes iron where
are all of your guns i thought this was
america and you're just gonna leave him
there i'm gonna chop them into pieces or
blow the body up like a beach whale he's
just gonna get up again
see what did i just say how drunk are
you people
prepare yourself for a film with a
message are remorseless serial killers
what we should be worried about or is
forming a mob to stop them the real evil
and like the former duh
moving on
so enjoy a muddled new installment that
tries to strike a balance between the
old-school scares of the slasher genre
the self-aware comedy of the current era
michael myers
go look go look hell no a little bit of
john wick
and social commentary usually reserved
for jordan peel or an a24 film about a
goat that stands for a miscarriage or
whatever it may not be perfect but it's
still a perfect example of a nostalgia
fueled sequel to a reboot made to erase
bad sequels that itself was a reboot of
the sequels that got rebooted to a race
in the first place and my nose is
bleeding again great
starring
the shove
strode rage a karen
ally mcsqueal i did my own research
lonnie
jenkins now i'm going in alone officer
involved rebooting the real housewives
of haddonfield
the speed school of hostage negotiation
better cameo saul
and hall of wieners
this is 40 years ago when michael myers
killed my family
the actual coolest part of this movie
realistic donald pleasance prosthetics
wow say that three times fast donald
presents prosthetics donald pleasance
prosthetics donald pleasance prosthetics
michael myers jason freddy who is the
most killingest killer who ever killed
we crunch the numbers to see who's got
the highest body count who's let the
most prey slip away and who's been
murked by the most babysitters across
their slashing career click the
thumbnail on the right to find out who
wins
this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond dnd is for everyone
dnd beyond makes it easy to play
register for free at dndbeyond.com to
start your adventure
by the power of grace call i
have the power